I can't no we're going to begin you
should have your books out we're going
to begin by getting your cert right now
if you have some person is there are a
little worse for wear so I know some of
them the glue worn off a little bit if
you've got one and you're trying to put
it on your table and it's not sticking
like try it out now to see if it doesn't
stick if it doesn't stick then I have
blue TAC out here that you can use the
put on that and then you can stick it
where I want you do it have a look at
the board right now you can see I'm just
roll straight line this is not just any
straight line this is spectrum so
spectrum is what happens by the way for
anyone who needs a blue tack will be
there okay a spectrum is what happens
when you're comparing things right that
are neither simply one or another but
sometimes they can be in between right
so for example we say oh we can is the
UV spectrum it's not like it's either
there's no UV and or there's you know
you go outside it you die because you
get sunburn that badly okay there's like
a range in between it's like oh it's
kind of a candidate no it's pretty
severe to extreme whatever there's a
spectrum so this is a spectrum now what
the spectrum is about is a spectrum of
probability or if you like I prefer
cadets big technical word I prefer these
words because they're words which mean a
lot more to me than a technical phrase
chance and uncertainty and I think there
are really important words for you to
write down the whole idea is something
it might happen but you don't really
know what might happen like for example
when I take this coin and I flip it you
will call what heads and very good for
the people who called heads cuz that's
what it was okay but you didn't know
somebody called tails you run seven now
if you were cooked enough to come in and
get a our post-it note what I want you
to do is I like you to come to the boy
right and use shapes that I have which
admittedly I kind of threw in there
because they are words that we use in
our language to talk about kids and
uncertainty but my own is common it's
some of them are kind of arms
kind of old-fashioned so for example
I'll go with this one first if I said
something is even odds right any
shanidar yeah but does anyone know what
that would be hands up how many of you
think you know yeah okay
maybe how would you describe even odds
yeah let me know I think even odds are
what you do what you get when we did
this before right even odds means you
have just as likely a chance of gaining
what outcome versus the others heads of
difficulties okay so I would say even
odds should be about yeah okay I've got
another one Buckley's chance there's a
line had their parents save them you
have Lucky's chance of mad
[ __ ] [ __ ] look let me let me try it
now tell you cuz you know how sometimes
in language you can know what words mean
even if you don't know what they need so
for instance ask me if I'm going to win
the lottery please ask me Buckley's
chance right now even if you don't know
what that means you can probably tell by
the way I said it
what do you think where do you think
this should be it should be it should be
pretty far over here I'd say it's very
very very unlikely right not like it
happens well actually I should probably
just personally I should say cube
because I don't buy lottery tickets so
ok one more thing yeah we'll get to we
get to some numbers in a second dozen
want to get this away which we won't get
there I don't want more such it's fair
chance
what especially it's me is that is that
very much again again something will
usually say to you fat chance
right which means actually yeah it's not
very likely which is very funny because
some of you have noticed that slim
chance is rightly in this area in fact
as it happens this is what English is
like I feel I guess I feel bad if you're
trying to learn it with your like you it
slim chance and that chance
literally mean exactly the same thing
okay because why is that by the way
asleep in fact you don't be why how on
what grounds could they be the same
thing that's exactly what is it sarcasm
right and this is baked into our
language that you can save that chance
with Billy sarcasm possible but
unfortunately that's what it means them
okay let's have a look at some these
other words you've got impossible I will
be bitter because it possibly is
absolutely no way it could happen no way
it could happen right and then on the
opposite end this is you see look at
certain yeah sir definite for sure I
know as possible as here now uh
Possible's a bit of a funny word because
what we're talking about like it might
happen or it might not
if you have to put a number like you
know what it what are your chances be
very clear on this
you can't really necessarily beat him
down anywhere right because something
could be possible but still very very
unlikely right like for example it's
possible to take 10 dice and we're going
to do a lot of things with dice in this
topic you could take $10 and robber and
it's possible that they all come up
sixes it's not physically impossible
right but but that's all very likely on
the other hand I could say you know roll
even number on a dime
and that would be right at the middle or
I could say you know it's possible that
the Sun rises tomorrow which is pretty
much yummy so this kind kind of goes
everywhere so I guess we'll just put you
in the middle oh you got a certain
definite for sure on top of each other
likely problem quite likely I think
these are all in bathmat spot okay
now I hope you've got the chance to
write something down yeah they're
roughly the same bright spots okay it is
by the way actually crucially important
but you get this language down right
this is a mathematical topic but
mathematics has its own language and
words and verbs but you need to wrap
your head around but it would have been
mathematics if we didn't at least try to
be can I can i express some of this you
very okay so for example kisi is one a
kid that says 50 50 50 50 yeah okay now
that's a great suggestion up for those
numbers before I put them down I'm gonna
try to explain why why I get to those
numbers from here okay now 50 51 in the
50 and the 50 referring to that's an
abbreviation actually tend oh yeah yeah
that's right these are both the same
right but why is it not like why is it
not 10 10 or like 20 20 like that's what
we say vision we don't say visions 5050
we say be just 20/20 yeah yes a
percentage is what we kind of think of
as total right so the 50 of the fifties
stand for 50%
right here 50% and 50% that adds on so
stands Theresa then 50 percents right
there in the middle then 0% will be here
and that means that right over here for
certain definite for sure you call that
a hundred percent right and in fact if
mom some of you have your phones right
and I don't know if any of you what
Kristen ups the area
way last night you heard the rain coming
in sort of late evening right and you
look at the forecast and it will say
like such and such percentage of
precipitation
right okay so we had this idea thank you
yes you should go you should go look up
the Bureau of Meteorology for why they
give you numbers right because that's a
great question to ask the question now
you can see zero fifty a hundred percent
I want you to think back to a couple of
topics ago when we did fractions
decimals and percentages alright now
just quickly write down here write
fractions decimals and percentages why
would these three ideas
why were they locked together and what
topic for why do we do them all at the
same time
very good right fractions to decimals
percentages and percentages right
they're really just lots of different
schemes for saying the same thing when
you've got like you know not quite the
whole thing or some part of it okay so
let's write down we've got percentages
already on here right let's write all of
these as well as fractions what's up
what's 50 percent as a fraction gotta be
come up 50 percent it's a heart right
uh-huh
the reason why you know it's a half is
because what does percent leading in
percent it means out of a hundred fifty
out of a hundred is the same as one else
who we call them equivalent fractions
don't we okay so you go one hour two
over there
what's your present is a fraction it's
just zero isn't it I guess I need to
press recommend is it or not okay and a
hundred percent as a fraction is a
hundred out of a hundred which is one
okay so I can write a probability as a
percentage I can write it as a fraction
but I also could write it as a decimal
I've got one more color we have it all
used okay
so for instance uh-huh how did you write
that as a decimal zero point five
one is already a decimal is it I suppose
you could say one point zero but that
you don't really even do that and in the
same way this fraction zero is also a
decimal you could buy a zero point zero
as well but there are all different ways
of saying the same thing okay so that's
why we would say okay if I said if I
said this coin toss right
I could say the probability of getting
four logical tails
okay but probably the details you could
say it's either 50% getting tails 1/2 or
0.5 okay now let's actually write that
down because we're gonna introduce some
language in here and some notation to
make things easy for what I just said
right the kids or let's use the proper
word out probability the probability of
flipping titles is 50% or you could
write 1/2 or you could write 0.5 they
all mean the same thing that's right if
it's a fair quit okay which I hope it is
now this you can see is true but it's
very long and you guys know that
mathematicians are always searching for
more concise or more efficient ways to
say anything
you can probably guess in this topic
we're gonna start a lot of sentences by
saying that probability of probability
it is probability that all different
kinds of things that might happen so
instead of writing that we just simply
abbreviate it by saying hey okay pay for
probability right so that's my
abbreviation so when you see the letter
P what it tends to ETA
especially when you see these kinds of
you know language or numbers is a
probability now when I say all flipping
tails again that's a really long way to
say it you could even just say the
probability of tails because you kind of
assume you're unless you're on committee
just drop it on the ground
okay so instead what I do saying this
whole sentence is I write brackets here
and what I put in the brackets is the
event might be Trish to do okay which is
tails okay yes good so I just want to
make sure we've got the right location
together so this is the event that we're
interested okay and lastly I say well
that's you know I have a symbol for ears
which is okay it's that and I could say
50% I could say 1/2 barcode to 0-5 they
don't be the same okay I guess I'll
write a huff okay now we know kind of
intuitively that it's a half how far did
you get Thursday into explaining why is
it a half where do the one of the two
come from yeah yeah fantastic so there
was a phrase for possible outcomes which
is correct that starts with them it's a
two word phrase starts with s and s to
me remember for either heads or tails
that number of needs me very good sample
space good job that's this sub number of
the denominator right that's the sample
space that's the number of things that
could possibly happen right heads or
tails there are only two outcomes and
what is the one come form
yeah I said I suppose her it could land
on its edge but actually at least when
I'm but most of you guys fit but like
you tend to catch it I'll put it down
right so I guess we really only have two
outcomes right then we done in a
freakish point so two icons possible
that one of the tall is what's the event
how many of these events aren't there
like we call them favorable events
favorable as in then once you watch you
know okay now for instance I know it's a
bit silly but I could ask what's the
probability of flipping heads or tails
well I could ask that it's a silly
question because the answer is a bit
holders but I could still ask it right
what is the probability of getting heads
or tails
I've got it here right you're certainly
going to get heads or tails you'll
definitely get one of them it's a
hundred percent right but when is the
hundred percent come from it comes from
how many favorable events are there
heads or tails there are two and then
there are what's the sample space so -
so B - yes term - which which of course
is a hundred percent one whopper zero